I guess part of the reason we keep
enduring these opening production logos
is because all these companies know they
are temporary bound to die off at some
point so the production logo is really
the only permanent stamp of creation you
can make on a film in the movies Dracula
wears a cape and some Old English guy
always manages to save the day the
narration also the fact that it's Ryan
Reynolds doing it makes me feel like
this is a Deadpool movie and it isn't
and I'm forlorn but everybody knows the
movies have fully sins the word you were
looking for was since doesn't get much
more David Goyer than a shot of a
vampire flipping off the Sun it's
already been established in previous
blade movies that these vampires see
really well in the dark
then why the glow sticks as a vampire
rave about to break out do these four
not have coms of any sort why is nobody
said a word since they landed it's not
like I have to be quiet to avoid
detection so why here because this is
the cradle of civilization he would have
been comfortable here
Posey's position the people who suffer
from this disease are anemic they become
intolerant to sunlight they can't handle
garlic as if the talk show is exposition
cliche isn't enough movie Wikipedia is
us for a full five minutes with nothing
but words this is a blade movie ranked
pretty sure we're here to see exploding
heads not talking once now that's the
guy I want to hear but I want to hear
about this character blade or maybe even
see him in action at some point you do
eventually have a blade appearance in
your blade movie right because nothing
keeps the momentum of the action going
better than pausing every few seconds
for another stylized movie title okay
Wesley I want you to kill some vampires
pose for a title credit even though no
one is around to see you and run to the
next thing is blade doing a pirouette
jump here there's no one to impress and
even as a flourish it's simply not that
cool even though there appears to be no
ramp of any kind in the back of the
truck blades car somehow jumps over the
car outside instead of slamming right
into it late Trinity doesn't know how to
physics also is this how blade gets his
vehicle didn't you have to drive to the
vampire warehouse he just blew up why
not leave a car there also also he's
somehow got that car out of there in
three seconds flat that's barely enough
time to start it let alone release it
from whatever secured it to the truck it
puts secured to the trap right Harley
Davidson pulls the gun out of his jacket
turns around and fires away without the
motorcycle even veering a bit he should
have skidded out and wound up on the
bottom side of one of the cars currently
speeding through the tunnel
this works automobile deaths in America
would quadruple if the doors on cars
actually opened as easily as they do in
movies you could let the ultraviolet
light burn your face off or you could
you know duck also blade probably should
have led with this in fact why not just
drive around with the UV headlights on
always staked you with silver wowed you
ash he's human it's obvious how would
you not assume that as soon as he didn't
disintegrate how dull is this plate also
I'm surprised that doesn't actually
happen more often it's not like blade is
out there checking vampire ID when he
goes on these rampages and he has no
problem killing familiars how has he not
accidentally killed several humans
before not a vampire dumb said you're
sorry yes
wait what why would they want to set up
plate let's clear the cops are already
after him from the awkward Chief of
Police TV interview from earlier people
want to be concerned they should focus
in on characters like this blade
criminal and yet this guy gets steak for
no reason
also how exactly did she know this chase
and crash would end exactly here's if
she could get the perfect angle on this
setup also also why did he even have
fake teeth in it's not like blade could
have seen them until now oh wait a
second did he do a second take for
originally that spotlight followed him
quiet a long way as he ran but now it
almost immediately heads back to the
body some friends of mine made it
friends yeah you remember those actually
that's a valid question in the previous
two films Whistler has been on the level
of a man with no name loner where the
fuck did these friends come from did
they videotape the warehouse explosion -
how did the police know that the fire
had anything to do with blade when it
happened several miles away change of
plan Wilson I don't take these Cowboys
down what is he talking about he said he
had a lead which he never explains then
says he wants to take down Cowboys when
I thought he was just after blade who
are these guys and why did the scene
happen the humans have a new hunter and
you'd like me to kill him wouldn't you
yes
so Dracula was raised just to kill blade
they couldn't find any other option than
raising Dracula how about just get 10
large vamps and have them attack blade
all at once instead of one at the time
subject is heading west got him if blade
and Abraham Whistler vampire hunter have
been so good at hiding out until now how
did they find them this easy can play
don't you see what they're doing they're
waging a goddamn PR campaign don't you
miss the old pre Blade & underworld days
when vampires just ate people no guns no
political sabotage just eight people you
worry too much
oh that's why we're still alive god
dammit well that and blades
vampire-killing super skills but sure
was look I bet you're worrying helped
out a bit too I see you alone surrounded
by enemies it breaks my heart
movie tries to pull a motion from us
when the extent of wesley snipes mo ting
range is this pre twilight whiny teenage
vampires still just as annoyed cheetos
are delicious somehow abigail has
mastered the perfect costuming to lead
vampires in her trap also how does no
one believe in vampires in a world where
vampires are this brazenly vampire in
public places
extremely public place is suddenly empty
so very bad things can happen cliche
even in 2004 we're just buying a loaf of
French bread and head of lettuce and
nothing wrapped around it it's ecoli in
a bag vamp hole number four is knocked
out behind her so he can join the fight
later so why doesn't she quickly finish
him off with her knife boot before
walking all the way across to face vamp
hole number three now to get even knocks
this douche power down several times and
has plenty of time to finish him off but
continues to let him get up for someone
so intent on killing vampire she doesn't
seem to be in any hurry this movie is so
badass that even the thirty second
meditation scene we've all been
clamoring for needs to be seen from
three different angles what is it what's
to worry about the window the chain-link
wall the moon blade is at the moon
Whistler has sensitive information on
four different computers has he never
heard of multiple hard drives unless of
course he's just clearing his browser
history in which case carry on good
soldier considering helmet pique blade
for killing a human Whistler clearly has
no issue blowing away cops after two
movies and some change seems like a
pretty bland way for Whistler to go out
however you can also argue Kristofferson
got out of this easy by not having to be
part of the rest of the film
did blade just go super saying don't
shoot
whatever happened to make up your mind
feds such grimacing so emotion and what
about garlic does that work on hand do
vampires do you need like saffron some
going with the old bad cop bad cop
routine I see I'm not the president you
know that is if not Kanye can catch you
up to speed
I think somebody here wants to talk
about vampires is making fun of your
patient a way to get him to open up I
don't think Dr Vance knows the
difference between talking to a grown
adult and a small child delicious
physical intimacy very sweet taste skin
sounds good to me
Wow I'm going to the wrong psychiatrist
[Music]
lazy screenwriters oh you've got badges
and Wow just come on through no need to
sign-in or anything this seems like a
lot of rigmarole for nothing is it
really that hard to get blade out in the
open
have some vampires attack some humans
and he shows up pants boner police
station has video game little holes
where the officers conveniently come out
one at a time oh look 7th heaven is join
the party with no explanation or
introduction to the scene play dead
good on really movie it's not like they
ducked a punch and hit someone else they
dodged bullets and for some reason both
sides keep shooting at each other what
was their thought process well I know
those guys at the other end of the hall
aren't who we originally were shooting
at but oh well once you pop arrows may
glance off things but they do not
ricochet headfirst in a completely
different direction
it's literally part of the design to go
straight as anywhere why are they
running away from Abigail they could
shoot her while she's setting up her bow
good thing she also had a power drill
arrow in her quill of tricks and somehow
knew to load it up before she even saw
she was shooting through a door
conveniently slow police force waits
until the obvious getaway car is already
getting away before police force instead
of loading up a vampire kill arrow with
a chick from Stealth decides to put
Triple H in an app instead where he can
dream of having the ROC's career in
Flintstones chewable steroids whistlers
daughter a lesser-known painting for
sure but still worth a pretty penny at
auction we call ourselves the night
stalkers sounds like rejects from the
Saturday morning cartoon actually a
comic run of a teen issues in the 90s
but semantics what do amateur supposed
to be helping me careful blade as the
old vampire saying goes don't bite the
neck that frees you you think this is a
sitcom unfortunately no even with Ryan
Reynolds we are still short one guy one
girl in a pizza place okay first off
that's just rude second I'm pretty sure
we saved your ass back there Hannibal
Lecter you also should have just
decapitated blade when he was in
restraints at the police station
but you seem to want to keep this
rivalry going for a bit longer has he
been told about your failure all right
Prison Break here who has a total of 15
seconds of screen time and the entire
first half of this movie is the actual
villain why did you break him out if he
was just gonna hang back at the camp the
whole time my name is danica Tallis you
met her earlier
Hannibal apparently has a doom camera on
his gun in case he needs to give
exposition later unlike typical vampires
her fangs are located in her vagina damp
china dentata Sommerfeld managed to
treatment the cure and now I kill them
hold up wait there's a cure that changes
everything right shouldn't he be saving
some vampires man instead of killing
them all willy-nilly normal comics exist
in a Marvel movie with Ryan Reynolds
this really might be a Deadpool prequel
it's a piece of
with we were able to extrapolate a basic
idea of what this there look like check
this out you were able to extrapolate
all that from that tiny piece of armor
are you psychic
did it have a product ID number on it
did you find it encased in amber nobody
really knows the specifics of his origin
but we do know this he was the first of
his kind that seems really specific and
according to our information they found
him in Iraq about six months ago six
freaking months ago six months Drake's
been out for six months and hasn't done
has he just been sitting around eating
Oreo thins and prostitutes
what gives Oh Vancouver postal code
either the hotbed of vampire activity is
in British Columbia or someone
accidentally gave away their filming
location hey guy she's talking to you
apparently customer service is not
something they teach at vampire
tchotchke store training school for you
sighted people here's a little
show-and-tell line exists only to make
sure we quickly know that Sommerfeld is
blind
apparently orange is the new forced
exposition electronic pistol comes in a
variety of tasty calibers I like Patton
Oswalt as much as the next guy but for
the love of ratatouille does every
freakin movie need a cube this bad boys
half as hot as the Sun it can cut
through vampires like a knife through
butter who doesn't want a little vampire
butter on their toast in the morning but
did you just say half as hot as the Sun
the Sun that's like 5,000 degrees I'm no
scientist but I'm pretty sure 5,000
degrees it's not something you could
hold near you and still have any skin
left in the morning weakest link
the bad part chain-of-command has always
been their familias movie feels the need
to explain things like familiars fine
but having blade explained it to
Hannibal who would 100% know what these
are makes no sense the night stalkers
brought to you by GMC movie builds up
invincible all-powerful villain and the
first time he's confronted he runs away
sprinting sprinting sprinting ah jogging
that family wants wife two daughters we
interrupt this touching Whistler family
flashback to ask where the hell all this
blood came from considering when we saw
Abigail just a few seconds ago her skin
was pristine is this not the largest
shower in the history of showers the
shower is so huge they could wash their
cars in it or some elephants or Wesley
Snipes tax bill tech polymerase Oh Meryl
growth supplement genetic sequencing
enzymes what are fancy sounding science
words that mean nothing to the audience
I'll take MacGuffins for 800 Alex
there's an old saying go one man you're
a murderer
Philip million I can't kill them all Oh
God or just simply a mass murder I'll
just enjoy more you will enjoy it more
unless of course you literally mean you
are better skilled at enjoying it
vampires decided that hunting humans on
a piecemeal basis was too inefficient
why kill you afraid when you can keep
them alive
thirty seconds ago he had to be
threatened with death to even let them
in but now he's spilling secrets like
some sort of exposition machine time
changes all men I suppose shut down
password what is it harvest because
every complex and clandestine system can
be quickly and easily shut down with one
seven letter password that even the
unimportant night attendant knows maybe
don't have the blind person on monitor
watch Howard Dracula even know anything
about Whistler and why the subterfuge
what does it matter who he goes in it
would have made more sense to disguise
himself as blade if you yell a little
louder you can make for absolute certain
the intruder you're asking her to hide
from knows she's here knew that Dracula
was also the first serial killer who wax
poetic with notes left behind in blood
why didn't they kill Hannibal was
Dracula where that if this made enough
money they might need him back for a
sequel papyrus
no one's told a good fatty acid joke
since well never are we sure gory
actually wrote the first two blade
movies or did Stephen Norrington and
guillermo del toro just cut all the
sitcom shenanigans
we've already seen that Legolas here is
good with a bow and arrow so do we
really need an EDM archery training
montage ninety minutes into the film
just started reading the Emerald City of
Oz Nome King it's Sommerfeld recording a
new video every time they finish one of
the Oz books also Nome shadowing
what could remain a child forever
wouldn't you like that wouldn't you
accept that gift but she wouldn't remain
a child forever in the first film
Whistler explains that the vampires age
just slower than humans no better way to
get me pumped for a big action scene
then slow-mo close-ups of guns belt
buckles and iPod playlists this vampire
hunting scene is gonna be also this
fighting montage playlist contains no
Joe Esposito but they set up automated
circling mood lighting for this
interrogation those vampires really know
how to do things right
spare no expense if they hadn't waited
over an hour and a half to tell Ryan
Reynolds this nothing else played
Trinity proves how annoying and
unwatchable Deadpool could have been
juggling thunder Oh pop quiz hotshot
these headphones are impractical because
hey you shouldn't take the time to put
them on when you are already in a danger
zone B there's no way they actually stay
in during a fight
C you're just asking for an arrow to
snag on them every time you grab one or
D it's all of them moron leave the
stupid headphones back at base camp
Hannibal was freed and given his stuff
over ten minutes ago did he have to take
a bathroom break
where is he been so he fights human
vampires with no problem but runs away
from the dog version someone's fear
priorities are all messed up
why does he assume they're dead if they
truly are vampires shouldn't you have to
use silver to put them down a dickface
you seen my dog do the triple ages stand
for heavy-handed histrionics because I
haven't seen overacting like this since
my college production of trip to
bountiful these obvious air punches are
as fake as that Norway scene and thor
ragnarok king's fighting a giant pro
wrestler and these two a swashbuckling
and I'm one I owe Caine powder reference
away from calling this a princess Brian
sequel I'll just wait to go fold Dracula
for this moment right now because
reasons actually think those punches
would work you only have one shot with
this arrow and you can't pick a spot
where you don't have to shoot it through
glass so the formula mixes with
Dracula's DNA and causes an airborne
toxin that will eventually kill all
vampires but winds eventually are the
night stalkers just gonna retire and let
the virus do its thing while more
vampire killing continues and what about
the blood pumping facilities or what
this does to blade this movie definitely
does not have an ending
[Music]
[Applause]
friends
you remember those King Kong ain't got
the Babylonians worshipped him as Dagon
and now they call him Drake might go
down a GOG there's an old saying I know
it's in Texas probably Tennessee this
fool me once shame on the shame on you
it fool me can't get fooled again